cómo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hola que tal bueno pues primero que nada
estoy muy contento de estar aquí con
ustedes pero antes de que comience con
el tedh me gustaría conocerlos un poco
más a qué me refiero con esto bueno
quiero que todas las personas que hayan
nacido entre 1946 a 1964 por favor
levanten la mano
a muy poca persona muy poca gente todas
las personas que hayan nacido entre 1975
a 1979 por favor levanten la mano
y la generación x muy bien todas las
personas que hayan nacido entre 1980 y
el 2000 por favor levanten la mano
[Aplausos]
yo también sí
y todas las personas que hayan nacido
entre el 2000 y el 2010 por favor
levanten la mano
una persona
bueno
me agrada ver que hay distintos tipos de
generaciones por las cuales hemos
mencionado babyboomers generación x y z
pero qué tal si yo les dijera que
el yo haberlos puesto en un tipo de
segregación
aunque puede ser buena también puede
conllevar a ser mala ya que me refiero
con esto claro muchos estudios indican
que el hacer este estudio de mercado de
globalizar a distintas generaciones
ayuda a la economía a puestos laborales
a estudios socioeconómicos pero también
lamentablemente puede llevar a
discriminación segregación y también un
poco de riñas entre todas las
generaciones
y es por eso que bueno les quiero
mostrar esta revista 'time' en la cual
una de ellas se hizo en los 90 y la otra
de ella se hizo aproximadamente en los
años 2000 la primera revista indica
creada por un baby boom un baby boomer
indica que
la generación x es una generación
perdida que nunca va a poder llegar a
llenar los zapatos de la generación baby
boomer que la generación x es la famosa
generación peter pan'
y que van a vivir siempre en la sombra
de los baby boomers
o también les muestro esta una famosa
portada donde dice millennials mí ni me
qué significa yo yo y yo que se refiere
con eso bueno la revista explícita
explícitamente lo dice los millenials
son egocéntricos y piensan en ellos no
piensan en nada a nadie más trabajan
desde casa hacen como fish les gusta
vestirse como quieren están todo el día
en redes sociales
acaso ustedes se sienten
pertenecientes a este tipo de
estereotipos la verdad a mi parecer no
yo soy millennial me encantan los trajes
y ahí estoy rompiendo el primer
estereotipo porque porque se diría que
yo al ser mi línea tendría que traer
ahorita unos jeans y una playera de
isidis y al presentar
y no es así así que
lo que yo vengo a decirles el día de hoy
a parte de contarles mi trayectoria de
como trascendi a poder eliminar y vencer
todo este tipo de estereotipos
paradigmas que hay entre las
generaciones distintas
es indicarles a todos ustedes que no se
dejen encasillar en una generación
independientemente de que sean
generación x generación y baby boomer
generación millennials z cualquier
generación todos ustedes son
individuales con diferentes metas con
diferentes visiones con diferentes
pasiones a las cuales van a llegar a
lograrlas si en realidad lo quieren y no
por una estadística de generaciones
y como lo dijo el señor ortega y gasset
yo soy yo y mi circunstancia así que
todos nosotros somos dueños de nuestras
decisiones y todos nosotros podemos
llegar a lograr hacer un éxito y
trabajar para lo que queremos
independientemente de la generación en
la cual ustedes estén catalogados en ese
sentido
y aquí es donde voy a comenzar a
contarles cómo fue mi historia
yo soy proveniente de una pequeña ciudad
del norte del país ahorita se me va a
salir el acento norteño
pero bueno decidí irme a estudiar y a
trabajar a eeuu a houston en el cual
estuve varios años allá trabajando y
sentía que algo yo podía mandar más de
mi ojo no por ser mi línea sino porque
lo traía en mi dna vengo de unos padres
que eran muy emprendedores que me daban
todo el potencial que yo quería y me
apoyaban entonces yo decía bueno por el
momento eeuu se queda un poco corto para
mí así que logré conseguir un puesto en
dubai como asistente de recursos humanos
en un hotel de 7 estrellas muy
reconocido para el jeque de abu dhabi
llegó a dubai estoy trabajando dos años
me ascienden tres veces en estos dos
años claro no fue fácil trabajaba doce
horas al día pero me apasionaba lo que
yo hacía es al ayudar yo a la gente me
encantaba pero había algo que no me
completaba a mí mismo y que era eso
bueno después de tantos días de pensar
yo decía a mí el dinero no me satisface
claro me pagaban en dólares tenía
departamento todo pagado agua luz
teléfono cable traje carro viajes todo
pagado como un expatriado
hasta que llegó el momento que dije
gustavo esto no me llena tu toalla pues
trascender más y hacer algo más por ti y
por el mundo y por el medioambiente y
por la sociedad así que llegue le toca
la puerta a mi jefa en ese momento y le
dije
jefa lamentablemente he tomado la
decisión de renunciar y muy sorprendida
me diste gustavo cómo es posible que tú
estés en el planeta lento ya después de
aquí te vamos a ser gerente luego
director te va a ser a mozambique le
vota será otro país tenemos tu vida
planeada
le dije bueno
lamentablemente no no me siento cómodo
en esta trayectoria de vida
y bueno me dice usted que haya gustado
no te vayas a méxico no te regresas a
eeuu
no te quedes en dubai pero porque mejor
no te vas a seis eles en áfrica y hables
una propiedad para el jeque de abu dhabi
y como se lo podrán imaginar a mis 23
años ya estaba en un avión volando a
seychelles áfrica que está en medio del
mar indio
era el más joven como siempre al igual
que creo que por el día de hoy ha sido
el más joven presentando
llegó si se les claro era una isla
desértica donde estaba baldío mi trabajo
era para ayudar al jeque de abu dhabi
para traer la parte de recursos humanos
y construir el hotel pero atrayendo el
talento contraté 500 personas hice las
reglas los regula mientos visas exámenes
médicos
tuve que despedir personas contratar
gente hacer estrategias de reclutamiento
las capacitaciones
hasta que llegue otra vez después de un
año llegué y dije
algo hasta que me falta tengo un vacío
que dice bueno me siguen pagando lo
mismo en dólares ya soy gerente de
recursos humanos a mis 24 años
qué es lo que me hace falta
acaso las pequeñas cosas de la vida son
las que me hacen más feliz que el dinero
así que una noche en uno de los cuartos
de habitación porque te pagan un cuarto
habitación con mesa de billar y ves las
ves las estrellas
justo en la playa del mar índigo
6 él está al lado de las islas maldivas
y
tuve una epifanía de la vida en la cual
me hizo reflexionar y nunca voy a
olvidar una llamada que tuve con mi
padre dos semanas antes
de tomar la decisión que tome y mi padre
esté muy sabiamente me dice gustavo así
como alguien llegó
de tu edad
va a llegar a alguien más con más
preparación con más estudios y con más
sabiduría y tú vas a quedar un poco
rezagado así que te recomiendo que vayas
y estudies una maestría para que tú
tengas una ventaja competitiva y también
ayudes a
arreglar todos tus áreas de oportunidad
en ese sentido decidí renunciar y igual
sorprendido mi jefe me dice que me paga
la maestría que me quedé en 6 él es que
es la maestría me las en línea y decidí
no era ya la decisión así que decido
irme a parís hacer una maestría
pasan los dos años de la maestría y
después de
de un tiempo en francia- decidido
después de 15 años regresar a mexico
claro fue una bitter sweet
en sentimientos encontrados los que
tenía porque porque me sentía contento
el hecho de que ya iba a regresar a mi
país después de 15 años
y ya iba a tener vida social algo que no
tenía en los otros países porque era
trabajar constantemente pero claro te lo
pagaban
así que bueno así como bueno este
personas que le encanta trabajar llegué
y dije bueno me voy a poner a postular
me metí a todas estas plataformas que
hay en el país y a nivel internacional
donde no puedo decir los nombres de las
empresas pero donde tú hay bolsas de
trabajo te postulas y a mi sorpresa
me encuentro con esta empresa importante
solo destrozamos solicite por expansión
requisitos sexo masculino allí
discriminando a sexo femenino edad de 35
a 45 años yo tenía 26 estado civil
casado sigo soltero
escolaridad psicólogo administración y
cinco años de experiencia todo
significaba que yo a los 30 que no los
tenía ya tiene que haber tenido cinco
años de experiencia para poder postular
un puesto de gerente el puesto de
gerente ojo yo ya lo tenía en áfrica
entonces al momento de llegar yo aquí a
méxico me encontré con eso pero dije
bueno gustavo no pierdas la fe tú sigue
postulando gracias a dios después de un
proceso largo y competitivo logré entrar
a las naciones unidas como asistente de
recursos humanos ojo dos puestos más
abajo del que yo ya tenía en áfrica yo
en áfrica ya era gerente pero a mí no me
importaba el dinero sino más el impacto
que yo podía hacer ante la sociedad me
apasiona me apasiona y me apasionaba lo
que hacía en ese momento entonces empecé
como gerente de recursos humanos y justo
me pregunté cuando vi esos esos esos
advertising cada vez que había que hace
que alguien estos 30 sean mejor o peor
que alguien en sus 20 porque algunas
personas catalogan la edad como si fuese
inteligencia y madurez acaso las canas
dan más inteligencia
o no serán más las experiencias que
alguien vive a través de la vida porque
créanme he conocido gente a sus 20 años
que han vivido más experiencias gente en
40 y viceversa todas las generaciones
son excelentes así que por favor no
dejen catalogarse en una sola generación
todos ustedes pueden hacer un cambio
independientemente de que tengan 20 40
50 hasta 90 ese es mi punto
y si son las preguntas que me hice
llegó a naciones unidas y la primera
sorpresa que me encuentro es bienvenido
gustavo asistente recursos humanos somos
dos de recursos humanos para 800
empleados
y digo bueno ok aquí tenía dos opciones
dije o me pongo a llorar y renunció o
algo hago algo o hago algo al respecto y
lucho por mi sueño por primera ocasión
decidí luchar por mi sueño
y no renunció sino a renunciar
pero también hice una estrategia en mi
cabeza porque dije el 90% de las
actividades que hacemos son
administrativas yo las quiero tratar de
usar mi innovación y tratar de pensar
fuera de la caja para poder
a traer más talento a la organización
para poder trabajar más y poder ayudar
al país que será nuestra meta principal
entonces lo que hice fue bueno en la
parte de software
al mes yo hacía 500 contratos
que eso me tomaba tres semanas en un mes
cuatro semanas su progenie lo que tiene
entonces no podía ser reclutamiento
selección nóminas ni lo demás entonces
dije bueno
conecte el
el software de nómina lo conecte con el
software de un software que yo inventé
entonces básicamente el software de
nómina me pasaba todos los datos de
todas las personas que ya habíamos
contratado y las ligaban en vez de yo
meterme a la manera de los 90 en word
hacer contratos
jolie que todos los con toda la nómina
la ligaba a estos contratos con un
margen de error de 0 ok y ahora en vez
de yo tardarme dos semanas en imprimir
contratos lo hacía en 50 minutos imprimí
a 500 contratos en menos de una hora
este fue el primer el primer paso que
hice
el segundo fue teníamos muchas vacantes
público 20 vacantes al mes no me puedo
ir a la semana perdón no me puedo
dividir en mil pedazos dije bueno haber
gustado piensa
no te puedes dividir en mil pedazos pero
bueno grabar en un spot y mandarlo a
todas las universidades del país con
todas las vacantes que tenemos y fue un
éxito porque no sólo atrae más talento a
la organización pero fue gratis le
ahorre a la organización también la
radio en la televisión
hicimos vídeos también en redes sociales
con el famoso hashtag martes de vacantes
que ya se ha hecho viral siempre todos
los martes todas las personas en
linkedin y en todos lados en redes
sociales se meten para ver las 50
vacantes que publicamos en todas las
semanas pista alianzas con influencers
hable contacte influencers y les dije
sabes que tengo estas vacantes las subes
a tus redes sociales por favor
gratuitamente y de ahí obtuve también
más gente postulándose a las vacantes
hice campañas publicitarias redes
sociales y todo esto ayudó
a que posicionará mos porque no fui solo
yo pues mi equipo y yo posicionar a las
naciones unidas por primera vez a nivel
méxico en el mejor lugar de trabajar
donde sueña trabajar la juventud era la
primera vez que un organismo
internacional había sido nominado y en
el 2016 obtuvimos el cuarto lugar en el
2017 la verdad quedamos en onceavo lugar
y en el 2018 quedamos en el cuarto lugar
entonces aquí pudimos poner en el mapa
naciones unidas méxico dentro de las
empresas que están de moda para los
millennials que es lo que se dice
gracias a esto también se abre la
posición de director de recursos humanos
ojo en cinco años yo tuve cinco
posiciones dentro de naciones unidas-
seguir creciendo no por tener esa
ambición sino era porque era me
apasionaba tanto lo que yo hacía que yo
quería seguir ayudando al medio ambiente
a las personas a la población a todo el
mundo entonces se abre la posición de
director de recursos humanos aquí muchas
personas este me dicen que ya éste se
está acabando el tiempo muchas personas
me dicen que no que no era capaz de
llegar a
a ser director
pero orgullosamente fui capaz y de eso
me enviaron a las naciones unidas a
nueva york donde implemente una
aplicación en la cual ya está abierta a
todo el mundo y a 17.000 empleados se
les puede llegar esta información
y para terminar les digo el momento que
alguien venga y les diga ustedes no
pueden hacerlo tú no puedes hacer un
cambio en el mundo tú no puedes ser
actriz tú no puedes ser piloto tú no
puedes ser arquitecto ustedes díganle
observen que lo voy a hacer muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]